>> Now when you're working with images,
there's a number of operations you can perform to manipulate them.
Some of these might seem a little trivial at first,
but they can be important when it comes to preparing
image data to train a machine learning model for computer vision.
So let's take a look at a few basic operations.
Here's a common situation,
suppose you've taken a photograph on your phone,
but when you look at the image file that's been created,
it's displayed in portrait orientation instead of landscape.
In cases like these,
you need to be able to rotate the image.
In other words, change the shape of
the pixel array and move the values accordingly.
Similarly, you might want to transpose or flip the image,
so that it's reversed into its mirror image.
Another really common requirement is to resize the image by
increasing or decreasing the size
of the array containing the pixel values,
and condensing or interpolating
values to make the image fit the new size.
Then, when we resize an image,
it's important to bear in mind that the image is
scaled in proportion to its original dimensions.
Resizing an imagery to
a different aspect ratio results in some distortion to the image,
producing a squashing or a stretching effect.
So how can we resize and reshape an image without distorting it?
Well, one commonly used technique is
to resize the image proportionally,
so that its longest dimension meets the required size.
Then, overlay it onto
a new background image of the right dimensions,
which will add some padding to the shorter edge.
It's like mounting a rectangular photograph
in a square picture frame.